es la historia de una caída vertiginosa
la de ftx la tercera mayor empresa de
criptomonedas del mundo valorada en
cerca de 32 mil millones de dólares
creada hace tres años la compañía
negociaba con unos 10.000 millones de
dólares de transacciones diarias el
fundador San bangman fritz se enriqueció
exponencialmente hasta alcanzar una
fortuna de 15.000 millones de dólares
creó un fondo de inversiones
especulativo y amado Alameda research
con el objetivo de ejecutar grandes
transacciones de criptomonedas a menudo
a través de la plataforma ftx los
problemas empezaron el pasado 2 de
noviembre a raíz de la revelaciones del
portal especializado coindesk que señaló
que gran parte de los activos de Alameda
research eran ftp una moneda de cambio
emitida por la misma ftx se evidenció
entonces que si el valor de los ftp caía
a Alameda podría enfrentar enormes
dificultades pocos días después un gran
competidor chino champenshow aprovechó
la ocasión líder del mercado de las
transacciones de criptomonedas con la
filial binance anunció su intención de
vender 500 millones de dólares en ftp
como consecuencia las monedas de ftx
Perdieron el 80% de su valor y cundió el
pánico entre los clientes que intentaron
retener sus 6.000 millones de dólares en
activo declarada en bancarrota el 11 de
noviembre ftx intentó recurrir a binance
para salvarse de la quiebra pero la
compañía china se retiró del acuerdo
tras descubrir un agujero de 8.000
millones de dólares en las cuentas de la
estadounidense las autoridades de
Estados Unidos investigan el caso con
cargos de lavado de dinero y de fraude
electrónico pidieron el arresto de
soundbangman Fruit en Bahamas donde le
fue negada la Libertad bajo fianza el
fundador de ftx es ahora presunto
responsable de uno de los mayores
delitos digitales de la historia